[Applause]
the 27th of November and exactly 30
years ago the clock strikes 12:00 church
bells ring sirens blare workers down
tools factories mines and shops empty as
the streets fill up with dance and hope
the historic to our general strike in
the middle of the Velvet Revolution
sought people from Prague to Bratislava
take part in a beautiful peaceful wave
of freedom courage and unity for me
these two hours go to the heart of what
the European Union has always meant it
is not only about parties and politics
rules or regulations markets or
currencies it is ultimately and above
all else about people and their
aspirations it is about people standing
together for the Liberty for the values
simply for a better future there's one
quote from the great vaclav havel one of
the heroes of 1989 that stands out for
me when I look ahead of to the future he
said work for something because it is
good not just because it stands a chance
to succeed I chose this good because
over the next five years our union will
embark together on a transformation
which will touch every part of our
society and of our economy and we will
do it because it is the right thing to
do not because it will be easy
we sometimes forget but our greatest
achievements have always come when we
are bold we were bold when we sought
peace where there was pain we were bold
when we created a single market and a
single currency we were bold when we
welcomed part of our European family
that had been out in the cold for too
long but in the last year's we had to
focus on the here and now
managing crisis after emergency fighting
to keep our unity and solidarity intact
if we have emerged stronger in that time
and I believe we have it is in great
part thanks to the leadership and
conviction of my predecessor jean-claude
Juncker a great European he has devoted
his heart his soul and his life to our
union and his legacy speak for himself
reload Maxie Dimitri me Ramsey monsieur
le mo mo de Parma ovarian iliac Ottumwa
Mousavi mccurdy votre conference Dupree
rencontre to legal politically chef de
taiga värnamo asam renews a vote for me
unique hip FOP an exceptional volum
ovary palermo have a addition is shatta
don't renew renew serve eight homey
DuBose akuti ESET exact moussaka - Ezra
continue era de l'affaire accompanied
Marcel Kovac a Toledo trauma Boudica
ledger
new Davos oovoo 8 a dacha a wee parkway
musician Baraka meses Ella democracy 11
or should we easy
occur the set dem
classy European Judah more vodka Suja
poor Inuvik
DEP DEP a lotta honourable members the
team you're voting on today come from
different cultures countries and have
different backgrounds and political
colors we have teachers and farmers
mayors and ministers doctors and
diplomats engineer's and entrepreneurs
we have those born before the Berlin
Wall was built and though I was born
after it was torn down those who lived
in dictatorship and those who helped
young democracies join our union it is a
team with almost almost as many women as
men only one woman away from gender
balance this shows
this shows we have made real progress
but also that we still have to do more
as the first woman to be president of
the Commission every member of my
college will have a gender balance
cabinet for the very first time and by
the end of our mandate we will have
gender equality at all levels of
Management for the very first time and
this will change the face of the
Commission every member of my team will
bring their own personal stories and
perspectives on Europe they will have
their own policies and priorities to
manage but all together we will be one
team that works in the common European
interest we will be one team that works
with this house and with member states
to tackle our generations defining
challenges we are ready but most
importantly Europe is ready my message
is simple let's get to work
honorable members this is an unsettled
world where too many powers only speak
the language of confrontations and
unilateralism but it is also a world
where millions of people are taking to
the streets to protest against
corruption or to demand among Democratic
Change the world needs our leadership
more than ever to keep engaging with the
world as a responsible power to be a
force for peace and for positive change
we must show our partners at the United
Nations that they can rely on us as a
champion of multilateralism we must
demonstrate to our friends in the
Western Balkans that we share the same
continent we share the same history we
share the same culture and we will share
the same destiny our door remains open
and we also share the same destiny with
our transatlantic partners yes we have
issues without any doubt but our ties
have lasted the test of time while we're
speaking thousands of students
researchers entrepreneurs artists
continue to build zillions of
friendships business contacts and
science projects these myriad of fine
threads woven together make a bond that
is stronger than any individual point of
discourse countries from the east to
west from south to north need Europe to
be a true partner we can be the shapers
of a better global order
this is europe's vocation and it's what
european citizens want and i'm happy to
have such an experienced diplomat as
joseph Burrell on our team working
alongside with yuta or pline Aliyev our
Hayley and Janice Leonard sheesh they
will do an
valuable job together we will invest in
alliances and coalition's to advance our
values we will promote and protect
Europe's interest through open and fair
trade will strengthen our partners
through cooperation because strong
partners make Europe strong too my
commission will not be afraid to speak
the language of confidence but it will
be our way the European will weigh this
is the geopolitical commission that I
have in mind and that Europe urgently
needs honourable members
if there's one area the world needs our
leadership it is unprotected our climate
this is an existential issue for Europe
and for the world
how can it not be existential when 85%
of people in extreme poverty live in the
20 countries most vulnerable to climate
change
how can it not be existential when we
see Venice underwater Portugal's forests
on fire
Lithuania harvests cut by half because
of droughts this has happened before
without any question but never with that
frequency and with that intensity and we
do not have a moment to waste anymore on
fighting climate change the faster
Europe moves the greater the advantage
will be for our citizens our
competitiveness and our prosperity the
European Green Deal is a must for the
health of our planet and our people and
for our economy
France Timmerman's is the right person
to make this happen
and I'm and I'm delighted that he will
be supported by Cadbury Simpson Adina
valium and many others the European
Green Deal is our new growth strategy it
will help us cut emissions while
creating jobs at the core of it will be
an industrial strategy that enables our
business big and small to innovate and
to develop new technologies while
creating new markets we will be global
standard setters this is our competitive
advantage and it's the best way to
ensure a level playing field
but all of this has to serve the
European people they want and expect
Europe to act on climate and environment
but they also need affordable clean and
secure energy they need to be skilled to
work on the jobs of tomorrow they need
to commute to these new jobs or to be
connected from home and we have to make
sure that those needs are fulfilled in a
sustainable way it is a generational
transition towards climate neutrality by
mid-century
but this transition must be just and
inclusive or it will not happen at all
it will need massive investment in
innovation research infrastructure
housing and the training of people it
will require public and private
investments at the european and at
national levels and once again europe is
already leading the way the European
Union will mainstream climate financing
throughout its budget but also
throughout capital markets and the
entire investment chain in regions that
will have to make a bigger step than
most
we will support people and businesses
with a targeted just transition
mechanism it will cut across different
funds and instruments and attract
private investment we need to help us
achieve this the European Investment
Bank will be a trusted partner I'm happy
particularly happy that the progress it
has made to strengthen its role as
European climate bank is obvious this
will boost investment in European
technologies and solutions the world is
looking for but there is more to do we
only account for approximately 9% of the
global emissions we have to bring the
world
and this is already happening from China
to crow to Canada through to California
others are working with us on their own
emission trading system and Phil Hogan
will ensure that our future trade
agreements include a chapter on
sustainable development because we know
climate change is about all of us we
have the duty to act and the power to
lead miner Demond helm the digital easy
honk Merkley dinger enough for anonymity
on Undine pavan bad white meat another
community and serving to information for
10 minutes in inverted mobility
inclusion escaped kindness Zukunft owner
digitally zero on margaritaville saga is
de [ __ ] d once of Gizem vague vitae
bring vert
Vivint etiquette an automatism Deon's
mention fearful fan Sambas pedas Tang
Fong Shui and last order does repetitive
davido Holland's Afghan a gonna pin the
fabric or on shellfish amorous hat off
Atmos cooties password on site shanky
site her does was once mention our site
net andris computer a Miskin empathy and
creativity the flag robotic and somebody
time embed nails the digital is Iran can
by dint of items of come here about a
mammoth i-i'm still Namek damnit flag a
personal with outside hat
toss to tune was worthless which to his
namely meeting Patti intense breaking on
fusee design digital easy on photons
emulation effective and efficient emit
for Souls norm saw him by the Alice can
span of a an Austrian converse of above
energy and I revered for inverse ocean
on was planet yeah DD he tell easy won't
vote also does a shaft on the word shaft
on the favicon fun want of forend Anansi
tutors yeah shown by rights water only
Golson shots and sooo not a bomb off
near a sequence of address Ian mystic
Luke I was gliding darwood a marked a
snitch can be Muslim surveillance van I
hope patient watched and Abba all
Hornswoggle patient via t-shirts
we're muscle owns of an item and our
patient week in our him digital inside
data before invaders complete mom here
since we miss insurance are taking a
look in by action on the novel purposes
that to government seizure had quantum
computer couldn't stay until against
blockchain on clutter sure chip
technolog in damnit unstuff a bug linked
the mid weight is a 400m Lucas reason
con Muslims with us Susan and in Davao
via Dan immersed at such thousand either
last stones also a sauce bundle under
gate on the for
capacitate non-division Alfonso Joseph
finished had on that song done in de
praxis mahom - and I'm a guitar man
supercomputer
I hope is that cited by often wait mark
island Ireland a drive lies don't start
right not to about that is clutter
that's been become average moisture dust
we in Indonesian Gaynor attune I hope
here
Ziva bomb that's Muslims at CSI I hope
at Olivia shaft on industry incapacitate
normal teasing fed and wet perhaps
finished design lesson via instead
snitched Klein rain Vera for Allison no
fear saleable then claw innovation bow
Krueger had forgotten a father about
innovati involved out he visited you
know that you're about 500m including an
assembly here in our oppa dimension one
here named divine here for sure
see one year here at su contra Costa on
rebar from sue comes figure in first
hope to America minds I'm standards so
we gigabit network when search for
clouds nish know the whole chickens on
and for ending done of the nation can
avert sure that's all material the
digital easy honk doesn't it data
material click then we're here in our
oppa tune photon via our Whitman my
special era transatlantic DVD ovum under
for hiding behind Flossie thus East kind
water rushed and
and they said norovirus peridot
michaud's inferno katana name eating
ramen Gazette Sam prevailed on does
continuo hope a tune so Mason beard
eases out by the translation until
against via via Naropa for mention
heading next for marked on Tim get
nicked from start here London for
mentioning and escape Nikita whom does
his weekly then that was an su de
Mesquita wanders Verdi Reagan's Edison
reefer and photons Falun Gong Matata
need then fuels also appear had their
shots the digital identity absolute ER
on overs the priority once is thus fish
station on Kleist I'd evolved in
innovation fighter very firm on FZ % al
honest person but Soledad Thurman had
sent niched and I [ __ ] mal connotes
severe gamut automata she vanished and
I'm sick - there's any reason for n dog
then indecent - Loman a Kentner sir
Divya harmony oppa and even not Suzhou
women deserve an ambush I'm Dimitri
guillaume amontons a named art in
thailand on day 9 a musician pools of a
few gong stankin it can be a kind of
competent to the peasant fortune I'd
steer Ibrahim on that so I need are two
strategies to and weaken
[Applause]
yond and gibbous sistema cyber cyber
zika hiatus is the key aside from
digital is Iran is assurance ow
created the while confetti vet perhaps
finished a terrible patient on time
inverse to the shards and photo but an
EIN hi Trisha of a patient Forgan wiser
that's a missionary of visnu buddy go
far and Thailand makes me to know have a
need to share result nine reminds I'm a
platform shuffle cave is amaz 9 avatar
to Sai positions again to a new Azure
stack invaders for town in definites the
verge shaft when Noah saw Evan video
resilience Kang Allah out in fundraising
Gus come on Alice Kalinin ven via the
mines and fergan then veer of undeniable
patient Viet an outbound on tan bonito
physically she does her oppa ow
in digital inside either in a few
underwater spear invert thus can't or
Hoopa honourable members Europe has a
lot to be proud of we are the world's
trading superpower we ranked first
globally in exporting manufactured goods
and services we are the largest source
and destination of foreign direct
investment anywhere in the world our
industry is world class and high-value
sectors for instance making a third of
the world's space satellites and our
companies are at the cutting edge
holding 40% of the world's renewable
technology patents we should harness
this transformation power of the twin
digital and climate transition to
strengthen our own industrial base and
our innovation potential this can only
be done through investment and
honourable members we have to scale
up for years we invest less in
innovation than our competitors do this
is a huge handicap to our
competitiveness and our ability to lead
this transformation this is why we
should not see the next multi-annual
financial framework as a simple
accounting exercise the world seven
years ago looks nothing like the world
in seven years time our budget must be
significantly modernised I know that in
this field I can not only rely on the
experience and skill of Johannes Han but
also on this Parliament but public
budgets can only go so far
we must make sure that investment can
flow to where it is needed by completing
the capital markets union this will help
improve access to finance for small
businesses and startups to let them grow
innovate and take the risks they need
and the same goes for the banking Union
we have to complete it in order to make
our financial system stronger and more
resilient I have entrusted this task to
Valdez Dombrowski's the right person for
the right job
he will make sure our economy works for
people quality jobs equal opportunities
fair working conditions and inclusion he
knows that we need sound public finances
for sustainable growth and he will drive
our competitiveness and our
sustainability they go hand in hand
we should never forget that competitive
sustainability has always been at the
heart of our social market economy we
just called it differently
think of the family-owned business all
across our European Union they were not
both built and solely shareholder values
or the next bonuses they were built to
last to pass down generations to provide
a fair living for the employees they
were built on passion for quality
tradition and innovation the things we
make today may have changed but we must
rediscover our competitive
sustainability dear friends here in this
high house it was in this spirit that
each and every member state committed to
the United Nations sustainable
development goals and it is in this
spirit that paolo gentiloni will oversee
the implementation of the goals he
believes in it and I believe in him
the European economy has recovered from
one of the worst economic and financial
crisis since the end of the Second World
War the labor market remains strong and
unemployment continues to fall
however with clouds forming on the
horizon Europe should prepare for what
is ahead we need to rely on what makes
us strong
our single market a single currency it
is high time to complete our economic
and monetary union to deliver growth and
jobs by increasing macroeconomic
resilience we must use the flexibility
allowed under the stability and growth
pact to give the time and the space for
our economies to grow and at the same
time we must support member states with
targeted investments and structural
reforms I cannot think of a better
person to lead this work Vanilla's
Ferreira honourable members
last month 39 people lost their lives in
the back of a lorry after having been
trafficked through at least four
European countries it is a tragedy that
a mother in Vietnam receives a message
from her daughter in Europe that she
does not have room to breathe for those
39 people for their mothers fathers and
friends we all agree that this should
never ever happen
people expect Europe to find common
solution to the share challenge of
migration this is an issue that has
divided us but we should step forward we
need solutions that work for all this is
the task that I have entrusted to
Margaret akina's and LVO Hansen with
their different skills and perspectives
they will form a formidable team
honourable members one thing is for sure
Europe will always provide shelter to
those who are in need of international
protection
and it isn't our interest that those who
stay are integrated in our society but
we also have to ensure that those who
have no right to stay return home we
have to break the cruel business model
of smugglers we must reform our Asylum
system never forgetting our values of
solidarity and responsibility we need to
strengthen our external borders to allow
us to return to a fully functioning
Sheng we need to invest in our
partnerships in countries of origin to
improve conditions and create
opportunities it will not be easy
but let us remember the words of vaclav
havel it is the good thing to do
migration will not go will it will stay
with us and therefore I think a Europe
that is so proud of its values and so
proud of its rule of law has to be able
to come up with an answer that is both
humane and effective we should be able
to do that and that the same team and
the same team of Margaret akina's and
Eva Johansson will also be responsible
for strengthening our internal security
they will ensure that law enforcement
cooperation can deal with new and
emerging threats and they will make sure
that Europe whole our best tool to fight
crime is fit for purpose honourable
members when I was a girl living in
Brussels my little sister died of cancer
at the age of 11 I remember the utter
helplessness of my parents but also of
the medical staff who looked after her
with such cheer every one of us has a
similar story I know someone who has the
number of cancer cases are rising but we
are getting better at diagnosis and
treatment Europe will take the lead in
the fight against cancer early next year
Stella kiriakidis will launch an
ambitious cancer plan she's the right
person to make sure that Europe's
beating cancer plan helps to reduce the
suffering caused by this disease
[Applause]
the point is that Europe needs to care
for the things people cheer about people
care about the future of our children
and our society culture and education
are what linked our history with our
future this is what makes us unique our
soul our culture our diversity our
heritage and I know that with Maria
Gabrielle it is in safe hands this is
why I'm happy to announce that her
portfolio will be renamed Commissioner
for innovation research culture
education and youth
people care about fairness and equality
in every sense of the word this is why I
chose Nikolas MIT to be in charge of
implementing our European pillar of
social rights and fighting poverty from
childhood onwards he will put forward a
framework to ensure that every work and
our union has a fair minimum wage and
Helena Dahle will be the champion we
need to break through the glass ceilings
those barriers holding people back
because of who they are what they
believe and who they love these barriers
have to disappear period people care
about their rights values and freedoms
the rule of laws our foundation can
never be compromised we must ensure that
it is respected and upheld everywhere
with every country treated equally we
must focus on dialogue and prevention
but never hesitate to take all necessary
measures we need experience and
engagement and we're a euro van Didier
Reynders are the right people exactly
for that
people care about the air they breathe
the water they drink the food they eat
and the nature they cherish we can all
be happy that Virginia syncovich us will
be leading Europe's fight to preserve
our biodiversity and oceans while
ensuring our coastal and fishing
communities can thrive and we have
Janusz voice chikofsky who will ensure
that our farmers can also thrive as they
adapt to new realities between
transitions climate and digitalization
will bring changes for all but let us
there be no doubt farming will remain a
valued part of our culture and our
future we need a sustainable farm to
fork strategy from capital access to
young farmers to the fact that imported
food products from third countries must
comply with the European Union's
environmental standards
and people care about having a say in
their future the turnout in this year's
European election was the highest in a
quarter of a century a Democratic
participation does not stop on Election
Day we will mobilize Europe's best
energies from all parts of our union
from our institutions from our walks of
life to engage in the conference on the
future of Europe it should be inclusive
for all institutions and citizens and
the European Parliament should have a
leading role from the Commission side to
broth gerschwitz a-- an experienced
member of this house will work closely
with you to make this a success
honourable members we all know that one
member of our family intends to leave
our union
[Applause]
a vast majority of this house seems to
be happy about the fact that a very very
very small group in this house would not
be able to clap a clown
and I've never ever made any secret
about the fact that I will always be a
remainer
[Applause]
we will respect the decision taken by
the British people we will work closely
together to find solution on common to
common challenges especially on security
measures but one he'll think has to be
absolutely clear whatever the future
holds the bond and the friendship
between our people are unbreakable madam
Jami Julie Paula motel don't hurt own
daughter
Aseem m dr homologous oh noes action
come relief a David Mohney school cadet
until salade upon desuka new thorough
ensemble see new fiance zambia not have
a lower abdomen socket sur le premier
continued ahmad not on carbon Al Sabah
imprisons the premier plum Dolan America
L R astral economy kir a salami hacer el
équilibre entre la marche LS Oceana
en Sabah Sheffield only dollar
resolution des grands on Romo do llama
at Aldo mellitus epiphyseal mezzo Sombra
new proven affair SP renew the set a
spree optimist a volunteer
Delia tanto que afectan Bella Rideau de
faire pour on Gavin irreversible Iliad a
million European kiss Angus Paskus a lab
on shows affair yessir key service
teaspoon of sailor community
Ieyasu kid on the laptop of Pontus wanda
personally will poor network back yes
turkey shot down LaRue
mezzo see Sean
still de'vide popota Sheila tema de
Jacques evil faire la différence news
hace para llamar can say a commission
news o SI nous devons faire la
différence
said on 30 speak Couric on stream on a
keeper they said onset is pre purchase
with ICI aujourd'hui the Volvo poured on
Monday
what confianza metal news o travail I
found approval dear don't totter
Eagleman we've loved up a sliver of OPA
long live Europe
living
[Applause]
let's see